♪ ♪
GREG: SO TAKE A LOOK AT OUR
STUDIO AUDIENCE --
YEP.
NOT A SOUL.
COMPLETELY EMPTY WHY IS THAT?
IT’S NOT BECAUSE I HAD TWO
BURRITOS FOR LUNCH IT’S BECAUSE
OWE DON’T WANT TO RISK THE
HEALTH OF OUR AWESOME FANS NOW
SHOWS ARE DOING SIMILAR THING
SETH MEYERS THEY’RE GOING
WITHOUT WITH AN AUDIENCE BUT HEY
THEY’RE USED TO IT.
SEE THAT’S WHERE AUDIENCE WOULD
LAUGH.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU CAN’T HEAR IT BECAUSE
THEY’RE NOT HERE IN THE STUDIO.
BUT IT FEELS GOOD TO LAUGH.
SOMEONE MAS TO OR THE VIRUS HAS
WON.
SO LET’S SEE WHERE WE STAND --
SOME PEOPLE ARE FREAKING OUT
GOING TO COSTCO BUYING CASES OF
TOILET PAPER I DON’T GET THIS
REFLEX AND WHEN I PANICKING I
DON’T THINK ABOUT HOW I’M GOING
TO WIPE MY ASS AND PLACED AN
ORDER ONLINE FOR 48 TOILET PAPER
ROLLS.
BUT THEN THEY HIT THE WRONG
BUTTON AND ENDED UP WITH 48
BOXES OR OVER 2,000 ROLLS THAT’S
ENOUGH TO TP THE TAJ MAHAL
ACCORDING TO THE DAD IT WILL
TAKE THEM 12 YEAR TO USE UP ALL
OF THAT TOILET PAPER.
[LAUGHTER]
UNLESS THEY’RE LUKE OUR MEDIA --
WHO ARE REALLY FULL OF CRAP.
I WONDER IS THIS TRUMP KATRINA
HOSTAGE CRISIS, OR NOBLE.
>> ROLE IN THAT.
LET’S JUST LEAN INTO THAT.
AND INCUMBENT LOST TO A
REPUBLICAN CHANNELER BECAUSE OF
AN EXIGENCY LATE IN HIS TOUR,
THE TAKING OF AMERICAN HOSTAGE.
PEOPLE SAID THIS IS CHINA NOBLE.
ENGAGING IN WISHFUL THINKING DUE
TO INVESTMENT IN HATE FOR TRUMP.
IF IT WERE CON CONTAGIOUS CAN’T
TRUST PEOPLE DRIPPING IN
POLITICAL BIAS AND CORONAVIRUS
SPREAD IN CHINA.
WATCH DON LEMMON FLIP OUT ON
JOHN KASICH WHO DUPGHT LIKE
TRUMP BUT REFUSES TO FOLLOW
DON’S SCRIPT.
>> I WATCHED THE ADDRESS TONIGHT
AND I THOUGHT IT WAS FINE.
WE NEED STRAIGHT ACCURATE
INFORMATION FROM THIS PRESIDENT
AND THIS ADMINISTRATION AND
WE’RE NOT GETTING IT.
AND I DON’T UNDERSTAND WHY YOU
ARE TIPTOEING AROUND IT.
THAT’S WHY YOU’RE HERE TOE TALK
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
>> CANS I FINISH NOW?
>> LET ME TALK.
LET ME TALK.
JOHN BECAUSE WE’RE HERE TO TALK
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
WAIT I DON’T YOU TO --
I DON’T YOU TO GO ON TO DEFLECT
TO TALK ABOUT ABOUT SOMETHING
ELSE.
EGG GREG: JOHN DIDN’T DANCE TO
DON TUNE SO ACTED LIKE A BANK
ROBBER WHO FOUND OUT HIS GET
AWAY DRIVER TOOK HIM STRAIGHT TO
THE POLICE STATION THERE’S A
CLOWN SAYS CALLING IT A VIRUS IS
LIKE A RACIST.
>> AS A FOREIGN VIRUS.
WHY THE PRESIDENT QOWLD GO AS
FAR AS TO DESCRIBE IT AS A
FOREIGN VIRUS, THAT IS SOMETHING
WE’LL ALSO BE ASKING QUESTIONS
ABOUT.
IT’S GOING TO COME ACROSS TO ALL
OF AMERICANS AS SMACKING OF ZINE
PHOBIA.
>> ROCKY MOUNTAIN FEVER ARE ALL
RACIST NAMED AFTER PLACES OF
ORIGIN.
EMOTIONAL BIAS SHOULD BE CALLED
CNN VIRUS NAMED AFTER ITS
ORIGIN.
BUT I DON’T HAVE TIME FOR THIS
AND FRANKLY NEITHER DO YOU
YOU’RE EITHER A PLUS OR MINUS
AND THOSE ARE ALL MYS US INS
ABOUT PLUSES ARE NOW CANCELING
EVENTS EVEN A CONFERENCE ON
CORONAVIRUS CANCELED THAT’S
CANCELING MY CLUB MEETING
BECAUSE I’M TOO HOT AND NBA
POSTPONED THEIR SEASON BUT IT IS
BASEBALL AND HOCKEY TOO.
LET’S GO TO ESPN TO SEE WHAT
THEY’RE IT SHOWING.
>> NOW LET’S GO DOWN HERE AND
TURN AROUND.
>> DOESN’T KNOW WHERE IN THE --
NO WITH YOUR BIG MOUTH, SHUT
YOUR MOUTH --
YEAH.
[BLEEP]
I DON’T KNOW WHERE IN THE HELL
WE’RE GOING.
>> I PREFER THAT PROGRAMMING
MORE.
[LAUGHTER]
NOW THE HOUSTON RODEO WAS ALSO
POSTPONED AN I WAS PLANNING ON
GOING.
SO TURNS OUT IT WON’T BE MY
FIRST RODEO AFTERALL.
[LAUGHTER]
YEAH I ADMIT THAT’S A PRETTY
TERRIBLE JOKE BUT I COULDN’T
COUNT IT OUT BUT YOU HAVE TO
SELF-DISTANCE AVOID LARGE GROUPS
FINALLY WORLD WITH HAS CAUGHT UP
WITH MESS.
A MISTHRORP MY LIFE IS ABOUT
SELF-DISTANCING I’VE BEEN DOING
THIS SHOW FOR FIVE YEAR ANSWER I
HAVE TO WRITE DOWN NAMES OF MY
CO-HOST.
POSTPONING GUTFELD MONOLOGUE
BECAUSE OF THE VIRUS MOVE INTO
FALL BECAUSE AGAIN IT IS ABOUT
YOU THE FANS BEING SAFE.
THEY POSTPONED COACHELLA WHICH
MEANS SOMEWHERE IN THE UNITED
STATES THERE ARE 75 MEDIOCRE
BANDS UNPACKING THEIR BONGS
LET’S NOT FORGET WIENER MOBILE,
THEY CANCELED THEIR EVENTS TOO
WHAT WILL I DO WITH MY BUNS?
WELL I DO HAVE A CASE OF TOILET
PAPER.
MEANWHILE THE STOCK MARKET
REACTS TO FEAR IN GOSSIP THAT
THE NEXT DAY IT WAKES UP
HUNGOVER AND CORRECTS ITSELF IT
IS UP AND DOWN AND UP AND DOWN
LIKE YOU’RE DATING LOHAN BUT IT
IS A LIVING ORGANISM REACTING TO
FEARS OF THE UNKNOWN THAT’S A
REAL PROBLEM WE’RE HUMAN AND
FEAR EXIST BECAUSE WE’RE LIVING
IN A CLOUD OF UNKNOWN AND FEAR
FILLS THAT EMPTY SPACE WHERE
FACTS SHOULD BE THAT CAN CREATE
PANELLIC.
BUT PANIC IN FORMATION A BECOMES
CONTROL AND THEN PREPARATION AND
THAT’S GOOD.
SO YOU HAVE A WAR OF
PERSPECTIVES ON ONE HAND YOU’VE
PEOPLE PUTTING DEATH RISK ARE IN
CONTEXT BY COMPARING TO OTHER
KILL RS LIKE CANCER AND HEART
DISEASE.
BUT BE THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE
WHOING FLAG THIS VIRUSES FAST
SPREAD WHICH MUST BE SLOWED SO
HOSPITALS CAN FEEL INCOMING SICK
INSTEAD OF CARE AND THESE CAN BE
RIGHT BUT SECOND ONE IS ONE THAT
REALLY MATTERS BECAUSE IT
ENABLES ACTION.
TRUE IN A FEW MONTHS WE MAY LOOK
BACK AND THINK WOW WE OVERDID IT
WE’RE SUCH FOOLS BUT I’M OKAY
WITH BEING THAT FOOL AND SO
SHOULD YOU.
NOW HOW IMPORTANT IS PRESIDENT
IN ALL OF THIS HE’S GOT TO BE
FORCEFUL IN ALASKA WHICH HE’S
BEEN AND STAY OUT OF THE WAY SO
EXPERTS CAN DO THEIR JOBS.
BUT BECAUSE HE CAN’T VANQUISH A
VIRUS HE CAN ONLY PREPARE FOR IT
AVOID IT UNTIL IT LEAVE.
AND TRUMP STRUGGLES FOR WORDS
FOR THAT.
BUT TO ITS CREDIT, HE’S FOUND
THE D --
CLOSING BORDER, BOUGHT US TIME
FOR EFFECTIVE MEASURES, AND ALSO
MISTAKES --
WITHOUT A HEAD START IN ARE BUST
ECONOMY THE THE TESTINGNESS
COULD HAVE BEEN DEVASTATING.
LET’S HOPE IT WON’T END UP THAT
WAY BUT IT IS WRONG TO COMPARE
THIS TO A PAST FLU BECAUSE WE
WITH DON’T KNOW WHERE THIS COULD
END UP.
IT IS LIKE COMPARING LAST YEAR
SUPER BOWL TO NEXT YEAR’S
CRUCIAL INFO IS MISSING.
THE FUTURE --
A BETTER COMPARISON, 9/11 TERROR
LIKE A VIRUS ALREADY HERE AND
MUTATES TO SURVIVE IT IS
INVISIBLE, GOAL IS TO GET PAST
DEFENSES AND CREATESES FEAR
BECAUSE IT’S OUT OF YOUR
CONTROL.
GOOD NEWS IS YOU CAN GAIN
CONTROL BUT DOING PROTECTIVE
THINGS.
FIRST REALIZE THAT WE’RE ALL IN
THIS TOGETHER EVEN WASHING YOUR
HANDS AND SELF-DISTANCING
REDUCES RISK FOR EVERYONE.
STAYING IN --
CHECKING YES OR NO OLDER
RELATIVES, EXERCISING AT A HOME.
THESE ACTS ARE IMPORTANT.
MORE IMPORTANT THAN YOU REALIZE.
YOU’RE REDUCING TRANSMISSION,
YOU SAVE LIVES, SIMPLY BY
STAYING IN AND THAT IS
FANTASTIC.
JUST WATCHING THE SHOW AT HOME
REDUCES RISK OF DISEASE --
NOTE THIS DOESN’T WORK WITH
OTHER SHOWS.
ESPECIALLY JESSES --
[LAUGHTER]
THE BRIGHT SIDE THESE BEHAVIORS
MAY REDUCE OVERALL A FATALITY OF
OTHER VIRUSES.
AND YEAH WE CAN TELL YOU SOME
MORE GOOD NEWS, JUST TO MAKE YOU
FEEL GOOD BUT IT IS BETTER TO
GIVE YOU INFORMATION TO DO SOME
GOOD.
IGNORE MINOR DIFFERENCES FOR
LARGEST SIMILARITY THAT WE’RE
ALL A HUMAN AND A A LITTLE
SCARED.
BUT WE CAN ALL REDUCE THE STRAIN
BY CONTRADICTING WHAT WE CAN TO
THE SHARED EFFORT BECAUSE THIS
IS A BIG WAR AGAINST THE TINIEST
OF THINGS.
IT IS INVISIBLE YOU DON’T KNOW
IF IT IS THERE OR NOT AND YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU CAN DID AND
KNOWING THAT ALONE WILL MAKE YOU
HERO IN A WORLD WHERE WE CAN USE
A FEW MORE.
>> CLAP, CLAP AUDIENCE, CLAPS
RIGHT --
OH.
GREG: LET’S WELCOME TONIGHT’S
GUEST SHE’S A LADY WITH THE
DRAWL WHO IS READY TO BRAWL
DAGEN MCDOWELL.
SO SHARP HE CAN’T HOLD A BALLOON
TV WRITER ARE PRODUCER ROB LONG
SHE’S ZANY BRAINY STIEWMS
COMPLAINNY HOST OF FOX NATION
KAT TIMPF AND KILL YOU WITH HIS
EYE BRO FORMER CIA OPERATIVE
BLACK FILES DECLASSIFIED OH, MY
GOD ON SCIENCE CHANNEL, MIKE
BAKER.
YES.
YOU KNOW GREAT THING ABOUT NOT
HAVING AN AUDIENCE I DON’T FEEL
BAD WHEN SOMEBODY GETS MORE
APPLAUSE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN LIKE YOU’RE
SOMEBODY IS MIGHT LIKE DAGEN
MORE THAN MIKE AND MIKE AT END
FEEL REALLY BAD.
YOUR EGG GO IS FRAGILE EVERYONE
DURING TIMES OF GREAT MISERY
HE’S WORRIED ABOUT HOW MUCH
APPLAUSE HE GETS.
>>I CANT PANDER LIKE HILLARY
CLINTON AND EVERYBODY --
>> YOU CAN TO US.
GREG: WHENEVER YOU LAND A JOKE
THAT THEY DON’T LIKE ALL YOU
HAVE TO DO IS SAY, BUT WHAT
ABOUT HILLARY?
YOU GET SO MUCH APPLAUSE.
>> CONSTITUTION.
THE CONSTITUTION.
YEAH SO DAGEN YOU ARE MIND HERE.
I HAVE SO MANY QUESTIONS TWO OF
THEM WHY DO WE KEEP SHOWING DOW
TICKER BECAUSE THAT IS LIKE --
WATCHING A SLOW ROLLING DISASTER
LIKE TURN IT OFF A.
GET IT OFF THE SCREEN FOR FEW
HOURS.
I MIGHT BE WRONG AND ALSO WE
CLOSE DOWN THE STOCK MARKET
FOR --
SEVEN DAYS AFTER SIX OR SEVEN
DAYS OF SEPTEMBER 17TH WHAT’S
THE REASON NOT TO DO THIS HERE?
>> THAT WAS STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS
ACTUALLY DOWN, AND LOWER
MANHATTAN AFTER THE TERROR
ATTACKS.
BUT YOU CAN’T SHUT MARKETS DOWN
BECAUSE YOU’RE LITERALLY JUST
HIDING WHAT IS REALLY GOING ON
IN THE MARKET.
THE MORE YOU KNOW AGAIN IT IS
JUST LIKE THE VIRUS.
THE MORE YOU KNOW THE BETTER.
BECAUSE TO YOU SHUT IT DOWN,
THEN YOU HAVE KABOOM THE
APOCALYPSE AFTER YOU OPEN IT.
THE NEWS --
>> IF I LOOK IN THE STOCK MARKET
AS A DRUNK GUY AT THE BLACKJACK
TABLE WHO IS LOSING AND I’M HIS
BEST FRIEND GOING LET’S GO INTO
THE BUFFET FOR A FEW HOURS.
THAT’S ALL I WANT.
[LAUGHTER]
NO --
NOT THAT EASY?
>> SOUND INVESTMENT ADVICE
THERE.
EVERYONE AT A HOME.
GO TO THE BUFFET.
IF THIS IS VEGAS BUFFET IS I
DON’T KNOW WHAT THE --
IT >> BUFFET IS AT THIS POINT IT
IS A TOXIC CENTER OF DISEASE.
DON’T GO TO THE BUFFET.
GO HOME.
DON’T GO TO BUFFET.
>> SNEEZE GUARDS ARE NOT YOUR
FRIEND.
>> MARKET SO OVERVALUED THAT
DOWN DRAFLT YOU HAVE WHAT 10
TRILLION IN DEBT ON CORPORATE
BALANCE SHEET IS IN LAST DECK SO
A LOT OF PROBLEMS THAT WE’RE
BUILDING ANYWAY.
AND A SO THIS VIRUS TAKES OFF
AND THEN YOU HAVE OIL PRICE WAR
AND SO THE WASHOUT THAT YOU’RE
SEEING IS CREATING THIS SENSE OF
PANIC.
PANIC AND FEAR BEGOTS FEAR AND
YOU HAVE LUNATICS BASICALLY IT
COULD GET WORSE IN ECONOMY
BECAUSE OF WHAT’S GOING ON IN
MARKETS JUST LIKE --
I WENT INTO WHOLE FOODS IN THE
LAST WEEK.
AND YOU START YOU SEE THE --
THE SHELVES ARE ALL CLEARED OUT.
AND I’M GRABBING LIKE BRAZIL
NUTS AND RADISHES AND I’VE GOT
LIKE MY ARM WITH BRAZIL NUTS AND
I REALIZE THIS IS CRAP LEFT OVER
AT THE WORST APARTMENT OF A --
CHRISTMAS PARTY.
GREG: I THINK THAT’S A GREAT
FOOD CHANNEL CALLED IT NOT A
WHOLE LOT OF FOODS.
YOU KNOW --
THE AUDIENCE LAUGHED.
[LAUGHTER]
HEY ROBERT YOU PANICKED DO YOU
THINK IT IS QIEZ TO OVERPREPARE
AND BE --
RELIEVED?
TWO-THIRDS OF WHAT THEY’RE
TELLING US TO DO FRANKLY WE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN DOING ANYWAY.
LIKE JAPAN DID.
YOU LIVE IN A HURRICANE AREA A
TORNADO AREA YOU LIVE IN A SNOW
EMERGENCY AREA AND WEST COAST
WHERE YOU HAVE EARTHQUAKE YOU
SHOULD HAVE 72 HOURS OF WATER
AND FOOD AND TWO YEARS OF TOILET
PAPER ?
>> NOT THAT I AM BUT GO TO
ARBY’S A LOT BUT NOT SAY YOU
SHOULD BUT WE HAVE TO --
YOU WERE RIGHT YOU’RE RIGHT WE
HAVE TO SACRIFICE A LITTLE BIT.
YOU WITH CLEARLY JUST BUY YOUR
OUTFIT, AND SACRIFICE YOUR
MOMENT.
BUT PREPAREDNESS IS LOOK, I SAID
THIS BEFORE.
THE BENEFIT OF THIS EXPERIENCE
NOW IS THAT WE’RE BEING --
TRAINING OURSELF IT IS TO
PREPARE FOR THE NEXT ONE.
RIGHT.
THEY ARE GOING TO KEEP COMING
THIS IS WAY OF THE WORLD AND
WORKS.
>> YOU’RE SAY WE’RE GOING TO
LEARN FROM PAST --
>> WE’RE GOING TAKE THIS ON.
BETTER NEXT TIME.
>> GREAT IF WE DID, AND
EVERYBODY SORT OF PREPARED FOR
THAT.
GREG: LOOK PROFITS WILL GO DOWN,
IN THE SECOND QUARTER WE KNOW
THAT.
AND STOP BUSINESS ACTIVITY FOR
TWO WEEKS ALMOST.
THREE WEEKS OR MORE TAKE A HIT.
THAT’S SOMETHING WE ALL HAVE TO
PAY FOR AND IN THE BIG SCHEME OF
THINGS IT IS NOT REALLY THAT
MUCH.
ECONOMY IS GREAT.
COUNTRY IS IN GREAT SHAPE.
WORLD IS IN GOOD SHAPE.
WE HAVE TO STAY IS HOME FOR TWO
WEEKS.
>> I LIKE THAT HE SAID THAT.
I KNOW KALT YOU HAVE SHUT DOWN
YOUR SINGING TELEGRAM SERVICE.
>> I KNOW AND IT WAS REALLY
PICKING UP STEAM.
A LOT OF BIRTHDAYS YOU KNOW --
UPSET I JUST THING IS --
PREPAREDNESS IS ONE THING BUT
THERE’S NOTHING ON THE SHELVES
IN SO MANY PLACES AND HAND
SANITIZER AND A SOAP HOARDING
DOESN’T MAKE SENSE BECAUSE
EVERYONE ALWAYS SAY YOU’RE SO
SELFISH CANNOT WASH, TO HOARD
ALL OF L THIS STUFF, AND YOU’RE
SELFISH NOT THINKING OF OTHER
BUT THAT’S TRUCE AND ALSO NOT
THINKING OF YOURSELF BECAUSE IT
ALSO BENEFIT YOU IF OTHER PEOPLE
IN YOUR COMMUNITY ARE WASHING
THEIR HANDS.
>> IF THEY DON’T HAVE TOILET
PAPER AND THEY’RE NOT WASH THEIR
HANDS --
OH, ME AND COLLEGE.
>> AND SQUEEZE LEMON JUICE ON
THEIR HANDS THERE’S NO SOAP
LEFT.
MEAN WHILE YOU’RE FULLING IT ALL
TO YOUR SLIP AND SLIDE IN YOUR
BACKYARD WHATEVER YOU’RE DOING
WITH THAT.
>> IN THE BASEMENTS.
REALLY NERVOUS ABOUT IT I’LL
SELL YOU PURELL FOR 1600 --
>> I KNOW YOU LIVE OUT HERE.
MAN I MENTIONED A COUPLE OF
THINGS.
ITO JINX GREAT STATE OF IDAHO BU
NO REPORTED CASES YET AND NOBODY
IS PANICKING.
WE’VE GOT POTATOES AND A LOT OF
TROUT.
A TROUT.
>> OUT THERE TOO WE’VE GOT --
[INAUDIBLE CONVERSATIONS]
ABSOLUTELY.
GREG: HOW MANY GUNS ARE UNDER
YOUR BED, MIKE?
>> NO IT IS A WALK-IN SAFE.
NOT A GUN UNDER YOUR BED.
NOT WHEN YOU HAVE KIDS AROUND.
>> ALTHOUGH YOU KNOW SCOOTSERS
IS HUNTING CERTIFICATES HE’S
GOODING TO GO.
BUT ANYWAY POINT BEING IS
SHELVESES ARE ARE FULL.
WE’RE NOT SEEING THE SAME SORT
OF THING THAT YOU MAY BE SEEING
IN OTHER URBAN AREAS AND PART OF
THAT IS BECAUSE OF NUMBER OF
CASES THAT MAY BE HAPPENING BUT
I THINK --
THERE’S A BIG, BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN BEING REALISTIC
PRAGMATIC AND PREPARED AND
PANICKING.
>> BUT THAT’S MY POINT OF IMPACT
IS GIVE INTO THE PANIC A
RATIONAL PERSONAL IF YOU’RE
SURROUND BY LUNATIC AND BECOME A
LUNATIC FOR LIKE --
MY RAD RADISH AND BRAZIL NUTS I
WAS HAVING AN ANXIETY ATTACK AND
I CALLED A FRIEND OF MINE I WAS
LIKE I DON’T HAVE TOILET PAPER
THEY SAID WASH YOUR BUTT.
>> BY THE WAY WE HAVE TO MOVE ON
BUT THERE ARE ALTERNATIVES TO
TOILET PAPER.
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE KLEENEX YOU
HAVE "NEW YORK TIMES."
>> BASH THE MEDIA.
CORN COBS?
OLD DAYS.
GOT TO BE REALLY CAREFUL WITH A
CORN COB.
JUST SAYING.
HOLD THEM RIGHT.
THAT’S WHAT I READ.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: QHAR YOU READING?